Sí buenas tardes
reiteró Nicolás Torres la ministra
principal escocesa que el resultado de
las elecciones generales que se podrían
realizar posiblemente en el 2024 si los
nacionalistas escoceses obtienen
nuevamente las mayorías en el parlamento
regional sería entonces un referendo de
facto por supuesto hay muchas preguntas
alrededor de esta posibilidad Nicolás
Torres dijo que los escoceses
encontrarán la manera de realizar esa
segunda consulta de manera de manera
legal y dijo que esta no es deseable
sino esencial para evadir el desastre
del brexit como bien mencionadas
insistió en que tiene en los
nacionalistas escocés es el mandato para
realizar esa segunda consulta pero lo
cierto Es que hay muchas todavía
diferencias con Londres en el gobierno
central sobre esa posibilidad se
realizarán esta noche varias
manifestaciones en diferentes ciudades
escocesas para exigir ese segundo
hablando de Independencia y por otro
lado Luisa podría cambiar Londres de
posición y permitir por su parte este
segundo referendo
es muy poco probable que eso suceda en
este momento no hay una posibilidad ni
política ni jurídica para realizar esa
segunda consulta de Independencia por
supuesto los nacionalistas escoceses
invocan a que tienen ese derecho ese
mandato popular y que no permitirlo
sería ir en contra de la democracia a
callar el sentimiento popular pero
Londres tiene en sus manos El Poder y no
lo permitirá Incluso en el futuro con un
gobierno laborista esa posibilidad es
casi que remota pero los escoceses se
seguirán insistiendo porque ese es
prácticamente la razón de ser de la
existencia del partido nacionalista
escocés el Primer Ministro Richi sunat
Fue bastante conciliador hoy en el
parlamento y dijo que quiere seguir
trabajando con el gobierno regional
escocés